طبعا على كلمتي الرئيسين الفرنسي
والاوكراني وطبعا عن هذا المؤتمر واهدافه
همم رئيس الفرنسي الذي وصل قبل قليل هنا
الى قاعه المؤتمرات تبع لوزاره الخارجيه
بالاضافه الى كافه المدعوين لهذا المؤتمر
47 دوله تحضر هذا المؤتمر سواء كان حضوريا
او عن بعد كما رئيس زنسكي رئيس الفرنسي
الذي كان الدنيا قبل اا همم هذا المؤتمر
اليوم الاحد التقى همم بين هلالين همم
تواصل مع الرئيس زينسكي عبر الهاتف واتفقا
على اليه تحضير هذا همم المؤتمر واهميه
هذا المؤتمر وحتى تم الاتفاق على همم
الدول التي ستحضر هذا المؤتمر الدول التي
سيتم دعوتها لهذا همم المؤتمر لذلك هي 47
دوله من بين هذه همم الدول بالتاكيد
الاتحاد الاوروبي لكن الولايات المتحده
ايضا هناك همم الدول من اسيا كال الهند
واندونيسيا هناك دول الخليج العربي ممثله
همم السفراء او نائب رئيس الوزراء لدوله
قطر السعوديه الامارات العربيه عمان
البحرين
من هذه الدول التي تريد المساهمه في هذا
المؤتمر الدعم همم
رانيا في حربها ضد روسيا الرئيس الفرنسي
اكد على ضروره واهميه هذا الدعم خاصه
الحاله الطريقه التي تعيشها اوكرانيا في
هذا الوقت في هذا الشتاء العصيب من درجات
الحراره التي تنخفض وايضا من جهه ومن جهه
اخرى استهداف
الجيش الروسي للبنيه التحتيه لمصادر
الطاقه الاوكرانيه بالتاكيد لتضييق الخناق
عليها ولتحقيق تقدم عسكري لدفعها بين
هلالين الى الاستسلام دفع الشعب الاوكراني
الذي يقاوم بشده
ويناصر الرئيس زينسكي في حربه ضد روسيا
رغم كل ما تعيشه اوكرانيا من صعوبات في
هذه الفتره وبالتالي استهداف مصادر الطاقه
محطات الماء ما هو امر يضيق همم
الخناق على الشعب الاوكراني على السلطات
الاوكرانيه وجعلها في موقف صعب جدا لذلك
جاء هذا المؤتمر بالتنسي بين رئيس
الفرنسيه الذي ياخذ القياده
والرياده في هذا همم
التنظيم لهذا المؤتمر ودعوه بالتاكيد عدد
كبير من همم الدول حوالي
يعني 47 دوله كما قلت اذا همم يعني همم
غايه في الاهميه ان يتم همم نعم
نعم
كنت همم تحدث اليك لكنك لم تسمعني كنت
تتحدث عن الحاضرين في هذه همم في هذا
المؤتمر همم وانا اشرت الى الصين الغائب
الكبير
نعم الصين الغائب عن هذه
المؤتمر الدولي
وعندما تم طرحها سؤال ان كانت هناك يعني
الدول المشاركه شاركت من تلقائي نفسي عن
تم الدعوتها كانت الاجابه هنا من يعني
الممثلين وزاره الخارجيه انه تم الدعوه
الدول التي شاركت ومن بين الغائبين ايضا
همم دوله اسرائيل التي لم تتم دعوتها الى
هذا المؤتمر بالاضافه الى الصين اما باقي
الدول فهي همم يعني لا نستطيع اعدها كامله
لكن من ابرزها ما تحدثنا عنهم من الدول
الاوروبيه امريكا
دول الخليج العربي الهند همم الاندونيسيا
ايه ده اذا التنسيق والاولويه والضروره
لاصال مصادر الطاقه والمواد الغذائيه هي
في قمه هذا المؤتمر همم لهذا اليوم شكرا
لك عبد الله ملكاوي على هذه التفاصيل
والمعلومات كنت معنا مباشره من قاعه
المؤتمرات في مقر وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
في